well maybe you've noticed i've made it a
habit to base monologues around the
reporting of chris ruffo
who's the city journal writer um does
a lot of reporting on critical race
theory and other things but the reason
why i base a lot of my monologues around
him is that he's
doing some of the most important
reporting in media for my money
um granted the most important reporting
in media is kind of like talking about
the
the cleanest highway rest stop bathrooms
in new jersey
kind of a low bar but in this case it
really is important so here's his latest
um he says quote the principal of uh
east side community school in new york
sent white parents this quote tool for
action
which tells them that they must become
white traders and then advocates for
full
white abolition this is the new language
of public education
okay white abolition white traders the
federalist uh
also has an article about this they have
more information they say that the
graphic also appears to have been
produced and dispersed by these slow
factory foundation a progressive climate
and race action group in
june of last year shortly after the
death of george floyd the organization
which claims it is devoted to
dismantling colonial systems of
oppression
and promoting systemic change towards
regenerative
social and environmental systems also
often advocates for equity-centered
education focused on creating and
delivering resources about power
structures
and historical social context as a key
driver of any topic
so this is uh and this is a group that
is now giving material to schools that
the schools then
is then sending to parents and using in
their classrooms presumably
uh continues some of the group's
initiatives include their study hall
conference series devoted to using
fashion
as a medium for social and environmental
change
and they're sponsored by many big name
donors including adidas tesla youtube
ted uh other other things as well so
this is a far left
organization and this is what they're
putting out and now this school is using
it
as for the graphic itself it says
this is what they're telling the parents
there is a regime of whiteness
and there are action-oriented white
identities people
who identify with whiteness are one of
these it's about time we build an
ethno ethnography of whiteness since
white people have been the ones writing
about and governing others
all right um if that makes sense which
which it doesn't
but then there's kind of the
illustration to maybe help us make a
little bit more sense of it
we're given sort of a dial which goes
from red to green
showing us the different white
identities
all of the white identities are negative
okay so they're all framed in a negative
way
and you wouldn't really want to be any
of them but if you're white then you
have to be one of them at least
according to the people promoting this
stuff
and if you have to be one then you need
to be in the green is what we're being
told
so here are the white identities let me
uh let me read them to you let me pull
them up
the white identities will go from red to
green so from uh
from bad to worse or rather from from
worse to
to not as bad but still bad okay um
number one white supremacist clearly
marked white society that preserves
names and values white superiority
white voyeurism wouldn't challenge a
white supremacist
desires non-whiteness because it's
interesting pleasurable
seeks to control the consumption and
appropriation of non-whiteness
fascination with culture
example consuming black culture without
the burden of blackness
okay so uh i guess for example a white
person who listens to rap music
is a white voyer all right uh
white privilege that's the third
identity
may critique supremacy but a deep
investment in questions of fairness
equality
uh under the normalization of whiteness
and the white rule
sworn goal of diversity okay so this is
this is actually most white liberals
they're not even in the green yet
they're they're
just according to to this they are
only slightly above white supremacists
these are the white people that are
going around talking about diversity and
all this kind of stuff
um and apparently that is that that's
for coming from a place of privilege
uh number four white benefit sympathetic
to a set of issues but only privately
won't speak slash act and solidarity
publicly because benefiting through
whiteness
in public then there's white
confessional this is another white
identity
you could be a white confessional if you
want what that means is that there's
some exposure of whiteness taking place
but as a way of being accountable to poc
after seeking validation from poc people
of color
white critical take so that now we're
getting
um let's see let's look at the dial
again
all right white privilege you're
basically so most liberals most white
liberals are back in the white privilege
they're
they're all they're kind of orangish but
they're still sort of in the red
now we're getting to white critical now
we're getting into the green so now
we're getting closer to
where the uh the race hustlers want you
to be
white critical take on board critiques
of whiteness and invest in exposing
slash marking the white regime refuses
to be complicit with the regime
whiteness speaking back to whiteness
then seven
white trader now we're really getting
there
actively refuses complicity names what's
going on
intention is to subvert while authority
white authority and tell the truth at
whatever cost
need them to dismantle institutions and
then finally this is where
they want everyone to be if you're white
a white abolitionist this is number
eight this is where you're firmly in the
green
and a white abolitionist is changing
institutions dismantling whiteness
and not allowing whiteness to reassert
itself all right
this is of course racist in the extreme
uh there's probably no reason to belabor
that point
those who know it's racist don't need it
explained to them
those who don't recognize it as racist
immediately are
hopeless anyway or at least they're
going to require a much longer
explanation
and a much longer argument than i can
provide here so instead of talking about
the fact that this is absurdly racist
which it obviously is
and that this is a form of of racism
that is widespread
indeed systemic in our culture
instead of talking about that i'd like
to pull back and take a kind of
panoramic
view of the situation if i could because
this is just
one way that self-loathing is instilled
in the population especially in children
yeah this was this was given to parents
of course uh because this is the message
that they're sending to everybody
but only imagine what the kids in school
if the parents are being told this
only imagine what the kids whenever they
end up back in school are gonna be told
um and this is only one of the ways it's
not the only way that self-loathing is
instilled
and it's it's not like you escape the
self-loathing by being
another race because that that that's
not gonna happen either
boys of all races are told that they're
toxic
that they're infected with toxic
masculinity that their masculinity is
yet another thing that has to be purged
and deconstructed and destroyed so
uh think about already now now imagine a
white boy
being subjected to this kind of thing in
school
they're they're just toxic down the line
toxic whiteness toxic
masculinity everything about them
they're told has to be deconstructed
they should hate
everything about themselves and for
girls
um it's it's the same though it's not
quite as explicit
now with boys in our culture they are
explicitly told to hate themselves
girls not quite as explicit but they're
still the same kind of message
a girl who finds quote traditional
femininity appealing who dreams more of
being a mother and a wife than say a
businesswoman
is told to reject that to hate it boys
and girls together are taught to be
suspicious of their parents their
families their history
they're taught to hate their country
they're taught to hate everyone who came
before them all of those
ignorant bigots who made them and raised
them
and it's not like the message to
non-white people and non-white kids is
positive either
because they're taught that they're
victims and that they will never not be
victims
that they need to be rescued that
they're helpless
there's a lot of self-loathing that
comes with that as well
so just think about this think about
what we're doing
see we thought that the problem was the
opposite
right this is the way that we've talked
about it for so long we thought that
self-love and and self-esteem were being
overemphasized
and they are but the self-love
that kids are conditioned into is very
specific
and very shallow and weird and backwards
so they're taught to embrace their vices
their sins they're taught to define
themselves by their sexual proclivities
they're taught to
reject their biological sex and invent
some new kind of
gender for themselves but underneath all
of that
underneath all that when you get down to
the bottom of it all
we are not turning kids into
overconfident narcissists not at all
we may be turning them into narcissists
in a certain way because anyone who's
who's focused intensely on themselves
and can't see outside of their own
interests
can't think about anything other than
themselves that's a narcissist
but just because you're thinking about
yourself and you're focused intensely on
yourself doesn't mean it's in a positive
way
so we may be turning kids into
narcissists in a certain way but
self-loathing ones
self-loathing narcissists we live in a
culture of self-loathing narcissists
we're raising generations of
self-loathing narcissists
because that's the message that's being
sent at the deepest level right
hate yourself hate who you really are
reject it all if you're a white
boy going to school and and uh totally
exposed to modern culture
especially if you don't have a family if
you don't have parents
they're going to insulate you to some
extent from that then forget about it
it's nothing but self-loathing all the
way down the line
but it's not just white boys it's
everyone to some extent
hate who you really are reject it be
something else
be someone else be who we want you to be
who we think you should be not who you
actually are
and then we wonder we wonder why
our kids are depressed and suicidal well
it's no mystery
it really isn't well i hope you enjoyed
that clip from the matt well show if you
did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content